My mission in life is to use product design...
...to promote independence in other people.
My invention is called "Cocoon."
It's a portable epileptic safe space.
My idea was inspired by me being an epileptic myself,...
...and I didn't think that should be an issue...
...that epileptics should have to worry about.
They should feel safe wherever they are.
Science and engineering have always sparked my interest...
...ever since I was a kid.
AirDisc is a new kind of cooling technology...
...that doesn't use chemical refrigerants as cooling medium.
We just wanted to create a product that we were proud of...
...and incorporated a technology and challenged us.
So, we created the Nah Yeah Buoy.
It's a buoy that detects rips by using a water flow sensor...
...which translates the information into different colors...
...similarly to a traffic light.
So, if it's not strong and it's safe to swim, it will go green,...
...and if it is absolutely not, it would be red.
When you see bits of rubbish in the ocean...
...or when you see waste, it's kind of an eye opener.
So, I went on a quest to create a bioplastic.
MarinaTex is particularly suited to single-use applications.
It takes between four and six weeks to decompose.
James Dyson Award helped me gain a lot of confidence...
...in not only my work but trying new things and new technologies...
...and trying to push my knowledge further as a designer.
An engineer is a problem solver.
So, for me, a good design is something that bridges the gap...
...between behaviors, business and our planet.